le coronavirus crest chloroquine qui
aurait imaginé prononcé couramment ses
mots il ya à peine un an a priori pas
grand monde
pourtant beaucoup d'entre eux sont
aujourd'hui entrés dans notre
vocabulaire
retour sur ces termes qui ont bouleversé
notre quotidien les scientifiques lui
ont trouvé un nom de code 2019 tirer
enkov un mystérieux virus à l'origine
d'une épidémie en chine qui inquiète le
monde entier 2019 enkov c'est le nom
donné au départ à ce nouveau coronavirus
le coronavirus qu'est ce que c'est en
février 2020 ce pharmacien en donner une
définition très simple le terme d'un
coronavirus représente tous les virus
une grande famille des virus et c'est
notamment tous les virus qu'on rencontre
dans les élections de l'hiver le 11
février 2020 ce coronavirus devient
officiellement qu'ovide 19 un nom donné
par l' oms l'organisation mondiale de la
santé
m paul vergès était nineteen autre mot
entrer dans notre vocabulaire cluster
comprenez foyer de contagion
je lui février 2020 agnès buzyn alors
ministre de la santé emploie le terme
pour la première fois après la
découverte de cinq nouveaux cas en haute
savoie
ces nouveaux cas sont au nombre de cinq
quatre adultes et un enfant et ils
forment un cluster c'est-à-dire un
regroupement de plusieurs cas autour
d'un cas initiale le mot chloroquine
fait aussi son apparition auprès du
grand public déjà connu des
scientifiques
la molécule utilisée pour traiter le
paludisme
le 26 février 2020 le professeur didier
raoult tu proposes et d'administrer ce
traitement aux patients atteints du gobi
19 alors maintenant il ya un traitement
qui vient d'être proposée par les
chinois qui était un traitement qui
était prévisible puisque la chloroquine
c'est un must un médicament qu'on
utilise depuis très longtemps pour les
bactéries intracellulaires qui victis
multiples cellules comme le virus et le
mot incontournable depuis l'année
dernière c'est confinement confinement
du confinement le confinement
ce terme fait désormais partie de notre
quotidien tout comme patient zéro
gestes-barrières ou distanciation
sociale
c'est mon d'ailleurs fait leur entrée
dans le dictionnaire en 2021
[Musique]